this is a small uh talk on meditation i
haven't done one for a while
and those who are interested in
finding meditation
i think the speed the world is going at
now
we're hearing more and more of people
with uh mental health conditions
this word mental health can be thought
of
as quite a drastic thing
i think we just worry more nowadays
we've got so much more
you know that
we're burdened with
than when i was younger
i have children pets
business you know
i thought life was as busy as it could
get you know i had periods over the time
where i'd almost had a nervous breakdown
perhaps i did have a breakdown who knows
and um
i never
seeked a great deal of help apart from
the doctors feeding you pills telling
you
that you know uh take these they're not
addictive
you stop them at any time
just to find that the
reverse
of what they tell you is the real truth
i can't remember there was one called
set that i was on
it took me nearly two years to get off
it
like it's a
it was a dreadful
i don't know if it's still out there it
was a dreadful one so getting on about
mental health
is just the pressures of life causing us
all
to have mental health problems
and other younger people
less likely to be able to cope with it
because
we may struggle with it but realize we
have to get on with life we've got too
many responsibilities
as i said if we've got children
you know a house to run apartment
anything
it's so we we've got ourselves in this
mess you can't sadly stop growing up and
as you grow up
even being at home in your own room
that's got all the best comforts you
could think of
but we can't run away from my mind
so most of the things that i've talked
about and done it
in life i've either met people
or people have just confirmed what i
believed in myself
i didn't read
much at all until i was in my 50s
so i didn't
obtain this information
through books so i wasn't
confused polluted or in line by books
i used to think well this is what i
think
and i used to go with that
and it's quite interesting that um when
you
do
hear somebody speak or you or you
pick up a book that you think would help
you'd like to read it
and i have such a book i'd like to
recommend at the moment
in this book here
it's um
you know he's a top selling
writer and also
a top meditator
well i'm liked about this book and it
may be a little bit patty my ego
but what i like about it is
he says
he's almost like i could put my name to
the book
you must have read books that
occasionally if you read books or you
might have heard somebody say
in us in a lecture
or just hurting conversation you'd think
well that's exactly how i feel that's
exactly the way i look at it
i'm sure you have
so reading that this particular book
i'm so pleased because i mean yeah i
could just perhaps put it down halfway
through and think oh well he says
everything i say
why why bother to read to the end
but what i like about what he's saying
is i've done a lot of nowhere near as
much obviously meditation as he has but
what i like about it is
i've come to the same conclusion that
if you sit in
cesar the lotus position
any uncomfortable position
we're doing it for other reasons to
wanting to meditate we're perhaps guided
by seeing monks in the kneeling position
and we're perhaps trying to cleanse our
soul
whatever
that is
to each of us
trying to become a better person so
we're having to do it by self-punishment
punishing the body and having to put up
with the pain that we may get in this
seated positions
so
one thing i'd like to pass on today in
this conversation is
um
the word meditation most people won't do
or would like to do but doesn't have
time to do it
is it so difficult to find a quiet room
do you have to wait for the children to
go to bed do you have to wait for the
traffic outside to calm down
well
some things we have to accept like the
sitting in a painful position
but my advice to you and it has been on
other
films
sit in a chair where you're upright
you're supported
and you feel comfortable but not
in a slouching way comfortable but in a
in a nice fixed
stabilized posture that supports you
back
as well as your
base
make your feet so they're comfortable
if you're a short person and the chair
you've chosen your feet can't touch the
ground
place books under each feet and perhaps
a towel on top of them so you don't
start worrying if the books feel cold or
slippery because of the covers
if you've got yoga blocks perhaps put
your feet on two yoga blocks don't try
to fit your feet onto one small object
all of this is about
making yourself comfortable
because
again as i've said before it's the mind
that needs to learn how to meditate
not
the rest of the body
we'll keep the body in this conversation
as something separate
and if you wish to punish the body in
other ways let's leave that for another
time
the first thing that um you have to do
that i believe
in the book
states it as well
is before you even consider
meditating
you can talk about the word if you wish
but before you consider sitting down and
meditating and thinking that
oh dear that was difficult
and your mind is busy or
lots of things where you
consider is too difficult to do
first of all
one thing he says and i really like this
you learn you need to learn how to
concentrate
so i'm going to show you a piece of
paper that i've prepared
you can do it on any card or piece of
paper this small dot
and what you do is
find a distance that's comfortable to
you
try not to keep
altering the distance
but try
i suggest
about twelve hundred to one and a half
meters
away from you
eye level you don't want to be looking
down you don't want to be looking up
you want it
dead on your eye level
and all you do is you concentrate on
the black spot
and you concentrate as long as you can
try to notice when your mind wanders
or you switch off
and you're actually looking you're
gazing into oblivion you're not looking
at the spot anymore so i'm staring at
the camera at the moment just to show
you that i'm staring at the camera but
really i'm looking at a picture over
here a picture over there
you know i can see
through a window
in my right side
so i'm finding that my mind's finding
lots of things to concentrate and look
at except the black dot
so
you may want to rush this process
but you cannot there is
my father used to say there's no such
word as can't
you can do anything if you want to
so
please realize that before you even
consider any of my meditations
we must go right back beyond square one
beyond square one
find a card
white card not a colored card
a white piece of paper not a colored
piece of paper
a round dot not too big
not too small
big enough for you to see
from no more than a meter and a half
closer if you wish but you don't want it
in your face you don't want to be
staring
you know you don't want to be staring at
this
dot
because
it's
imposing you know it's imposing on me
move it away
move it away until
your inner mind
tells you
i'm okay with that i don't feel
encroaching on me whatsoever
i now don't feel that i'm straining to
see it because it's too far away
you might have to do this for weeks
and weeks
if you could do it each day
for a few minutes and build it
you need to find peace you need to
unplug any landline phones if you still
have them
you need to
remove any mobile phones from the area
turn them to silent place them somewhere
in your house apartment wherever you are
and you need to find a quiet space
as quiet as possible
but before you start
also acknowledge
that there may be sounds
now as i talk to you i hear birds
whistling
and it's lovely
and
i can accept that
but
if my dog starts barking outside the
door i might think i'll go away
go away i'm trying to
talk to people on this film
well it's the same thing as oh go away
i'm trying to concentrate
but don't let that wow you let your mind
go over to the door and where she's
barking
and then bring the sound back to you and
know that
you must have heard the sound and as
i've said before
don't
you instantly go to the sound whatever
the sound is but then the sound owns you
if you can then just come back to
yourself and say okay
whatever sound comes
i will accept it in here
lightly i would just accept it
i might even thank it for being a test
to testing my concentration and my
peacefulness of mind
again
concentrate back
on the dot
if you've got your seat in the standard
position and then the paper is in a
or card is in a
distant same place just settle yourself
back in the chair even if you never
moved
sell yourself
perhaps have a nice outward calming
breath
soften your gaze
and go back to concentrating
on the spots
see through concentrating on that spot
and only on that spot
what you're doing is you're meditating
without knowing it
because you're learning how to hold
an item
without confusing it with other items
and you're being able to do it with your
eyes open
rather than with your eyes closed
a lot once you become good you close
your eyes
and perhaps see the dot
so by looking at the dot looking at the
dot
do this as i say every day for a few
weeks
and then slowly slowly looking at the
dog slowly closing your eyes you may
still be seeing the dot in front of you
and just keep concentrating on the dot
try not to squint try not to look too
hard
you know
check to see if you're doing this you
may not realize that you're
you're pulling yourself towards your
squinting
you can always have that lovely out
breath
try to smile
looking at the dots
within all of this
you will start
controlling the ego mind the mind that
wants to look at the picture up here the
window out there the picture down there
anything to take you away
from holding the concentration of
nothingness
now looking at a spot the dot is
something so that's not looking at
nothing less
um
but it's making you focus
on something other than any other
thoughts that may come into your mind
that bombard you throughout the day
the
mind is like a
flashlight going on on on
and there's so much information coming
into you
by focusing on
the dots
i think that it's up to you when you
find the time
i like to think how do i feel
reasonably calm i try not to do it when
i feel you know
all my emotions up in the air
i used to i used to think oh i must go
and calm myself i was going calmer but
you can calm yourself by just sitting in
a chair and just taking time out
you don't have to
rush off
pull the phones out switch everything
off
shout to your partner i've got another
piece i've got
looking at the dot you will soon start
gazing outwardly and being in what i
call a daydream rather than
doing what you're supposed to do
so the best time i think to
construct the spot is either first in
the morning or go to the bathroom wash
water through your eyes
make sure your eyes are nice and clear
and you're wide awake move
pull these odd faces if you need to give
yourself a little bit of exercise lift
your eyebrows whatever you need to do
and then
calmly sit and concentrate as long as
you can on the dot
perhaps before you go to bed you may be
tired but you might want just a little
bit of water again
and just peacefully
look at the dots
you'll soon find out when is your best
times
again
i'm here to reiterate please do not
do it when you're emotionally
entwined in whatever's upsetting you
because you cannot escape it
it's better to just go and sit
and calm yourself down
to think that this is the time to
meditate it's not
thank you for listening
i hope this helps